philippe boutin médecins généralistes
bonsoir philippe boutin merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
cette étude britannique évidemment il
fait froid dans le dos ou est-ce que
vous à votre niveau vous l'avez constaté
sur des patients dans votre cabine et
non sur les conséquences des colis de
longwy bien sûr effectivement il a un
certain nombre de troubles qui sont
encore méconnus mais qui ont
effectivement des connotations
neurologiques neuropsychiatriques et qui
sont assez durables avec des tableaux
qui sont assez impressionnants parfois
mais c'est un constant mais bon enfin je
veux pas non plus enclins à une
généralité
impressionnant ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que on a des tableaux dépressif
on a des tableaux qui manifeste une
atteinte neurologique etc ces
importantes oui mais qui sont dans des
proportions assez assez rare aussi pour
pas non plus généraliser on est sur des
colis de nom moi par exemple dans notre
entourage là une jeune femme qui est en
haut d'un état dépressif important
depuis maintenant cinq mois alors
docteur ça veut dire en gros on a
souvent entendu un les effets sur les
poumons des effets notamment sur de la
fatigue mais ça ça veut dire clairement
quand on parle de dépression et c'est
que le cerveau a été touché le point de
départ et on sait depuis depuis
l'atteinte d'annecy aggasy enfin dire
quand on a des troubles de l'odorat on a
déjà une atteinte neurologique mios
cérébrale qui est certes faible mais qui
témoigne d'une appétence et on est
possible pour les graisses aussi du
système nerveux des virus donc forcément
c'est une porte d'entrée et je veux pas
dire que tout il faut pas dire que tous
les gens qui ont des problèmes de l'us
navy ont après des problèmes dépressifs
non mais ça veut dire qu'il ya quand
même une appétence du virus vers les
tissus neurologique oui ça
jour sur deco vide qui était grave ou
même bénin ce genre d'effets secondaires
long on a pas de corrélation alors bien
sûr des gens qui ont fait des
réanimations et qui sont à juste titre
très marquée par ces périodes de
réanimation mais il n'y a pas forcément
de corrélation entre des manifestations
à long terme ni coheed et l'importance
de ces munitions est-ce qu'il faut
clairement s'attendre à d'autres effets
encore méconnus de ce virus ou on
commence quand même à y voir un petit
peu claires dans les effets secondaires
alors les deux on y voit de plus en plus
clair c'est sûr mais il faut s'attendre
encore à une surprise ce virus nous
réservera vraisemblablement encore pas
mal de surprises dans les prochains mois
oui or là je vais poser une question
volontairement provocatrice mais c'est
peut-être une question qu'on se pose ici
ou là les français et les autres
est-ce qu'on loue des tous selon vous
les pouvoirs publics ont dix tours ont
pas toujours forcément sur sur ce virus
on va sur le virus en lui-même et disent
ce qu'ils savent et ont dit ce que l'on
sait on en dit est de trop même puisque
on parle sûrement de choses qui ne sont
pas encore stabilisés je pense qu'il y a
effectivement on est dans un domaine qui
recherchent en permanence et c c'est ça
qui est limite passionnant dans ce dans
cette pandémie
c'est con on en apprend tous les jours
donc bien évidemment moi je dire depuis
maintenant un an
on a des des modifications de de
thérapie de protocoles deux fois par
semaine voire plus ce qui en fait
quelque chose de non stabilisé même pour
les médecins donc nous sommes nous
sommes en permanence en train
d'apprendre
en train de peaufiner notre stratégie
pour ces patients atteints de ce club
autre actualité de la journée vous
l'avez entendu astrazeneca l'agencé
européenne du médicament qui confirme
que pour la première fois il ya un lien
entre ce vaccin et les caillots sanguins
mais qui précise que c'est un phénomène
très rare on en me dire tout ça pour ça
disent neuf morts tout de même au
royaume uni en lien avec ce vaccin on
imagine que tout de même ça ne va pas
arranger la défiance envers lui vous
aurez peut-être de plus en plus de mal à
vacciner les médecins alors d'abord cela
sur la stratégie vaccinale effectivement
là pour nous que ce soit à dessein
pharmaciens et infirmiers nous sommes
dans la stratégie qu'aqmi plan
effectivement nous prenons de plein
fouet cette alors d'abord les
atermoiements de stratégie vaccinale de
ces au début ce vaccin était réservée au
moins de 65 ans maintenant il faut le
donner aux plus de 55 ans nous vous
voulez on a changé du tout au tout donc
c'est quand même extrêmement et ça en
l'espace de quelques semaines d'une
semaine donc il faut il faut être au
contact des patients pour leur expliquer
les avantages de ceux de cette
vaccination par ce pas une cas bon
maintenant ce que je peux regretter en
tant que médecin c'est qu'on n'est pas à
disposition l'ensemble du panel d'aidés
des vaccins disponibles puisque nous
sommes parfaitement capables maintenant
d'avoir une avoir des des degrés de
conservation pour le riser qui sont
moins quinze mois rhin donc sont
parfaitement compatibles avec des
congélateur médicaux normaux donc on
pourrait parfaitement vacciner à grande
échelle avec les médecins généralistes
les médecins spécialistes les
pharmaciens et les infirmiers sur le
même rythme que ce que nous faisons pour
pour la grippe par exemple nous avons
fait plus de fautes 17 millions environ
au vaccin pour la grippe hanche en un
peu plus de deux semaines je pense que
nous pourrions faire exactement la même
chose pour les vaccins que vide et je
pense que ce serait autrement plus
efficace que d'une espèce de barnum qui
donc sont mis en place à grands frais
avec les médias présents à venir la
vedette à vous aux médecins généralistes
mais aussi aux pharmaciens clairement
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez assez de
doses pour vacciner ont tout est un
petit peu transférés dans rendant ces
gros centre bell très clairement depuis
un mois et demi
en ce qui me concerne j'ai eu dix flacon
donc ça fait 100 doses que j'ai rejeté
immédiatement
je n'ai pas eu de deux vaccins cette
semaine j'en ai pas eues la semaine
dernière on en a promis pour la fin de
la semaine
j'en ai pu commander théoriquement le un
flacon lundi dernier donc voyez qu'on
est complètement à dose homéopathique je
rejoue 12
je rappelle simplement à la chine nous
sommes cinquante cinq mille généraliste
qui nous avions un flacons de dix doses
par jour
nous serions un demi million de vaccinés
supplémentaire tous les jours problème
c'est qu'il n'y a pas forcément de deux
doses en tout cas pas pour le moment
quand vous voyez que en allemagne la
bavière commandes précommande spoutnik
il ya d'autres pays de l'union
européenne qu'ils ont fait ça fait ch en
franchissant un petit peu des règles de
l'europe
est-ce que selon vous en tant que
médecin vous pensez que
la france doit soumettre également parce
qu apparemment d'après thierry breton
n'a n'aura pas vraiment besoin
avec ça je pense qu'il faut faire avec
les vaccins qui sont stabilisées qui
sont reconnus dans le spoutnik est pas
un mauvais vaccin d'après ce que j'en
sais je crois qu'il ya des problèmes de
production où là aussi je pense qu'on
n'a pas intérêt à multiplier les offres
en matière de vaccins par contre être
suffisamment achalandé et à avoir à
l'esprit suffisamment de vaccins dans
les 4-5 vaccin que l'on a actuellement
ça me va tout à fait je sais pas s'il
faut aller chercher le chinois ou le ou
le russe je ne le pense pas
personnellement mais bon déjà que nous
travaillons avec suffisamment de doses
d'astrazeneca de moderna de johnson &
johnson bref les files heures et tout ce
que l'on a actuellement et je pense
qu'on doit pouvoir faire mieux avec ce
que l'on a
encore faut-il les avoir effectivement
merci philippe beauté avec nous en
direct sur rt france